how how do you at that point when you're
going through it obviously we talked
about a little bit earlier when you talk
about why i became a mr nice because my
wife said you're passive aggressive
you took the uh the place where you went
to but at that point of the game when a
man hits it where he realizes
maybe this way of being a man is no
longer sexy
seductive attractive to my woman what do
i need to do
to win her over again what do i need to
do to be
and then they hit the wall when when
that happens
what are some things you've seen over
the years that's worked for men who want
to pivot and make adjustments so life
changes a bit with their personal lives
okay so we talk are we talking about
dating are we talking about
what dating and then we'll go marriage
let's go dating first and we'll go
marriage
okay that's fine because because i i
teach about both
so my background is that i i did not
learn to date until i was in my late 40s
um what i did in high school college was
not dating
it was i call it nice guy seduction just
you know hang out with a woman a little
while try to impress her a little bit
hide my sexual agenda from her and then
maybe she'll want to get naked with me
if i hide my sexual agenda you know
try not to be the jerk that i've heard
women complain about
and if i did get a girlfriend i just
hung on to them forever
so i was married to my first two wives
for a total of 25 years
i shouldn't have dated either one of
them probably more than three dates
i mean they're both good people but they
were not good matches for me
now i'm grateful for them both i learned
a lot i grew a lot
and and i wrote a book because of the
second marriage
but i got divorced in my late 40s and i
had no clue how to date now going back
to neil stross
and strauss in the game um that book had
just come out
and and pickup was really on the rise
then
and and in that place where else are you
gonna go get education about dating
right and so i read the book and you
know learned a lot about it
about about with that and guys gave me
you know podcasts that were starting to
come out and books and videos and david
d'angelo and
a lot of people doing the dating stuff
and i just went out
and and just i never really liked the
pickup idea i didn't like the idea of
just approaching a woman because she was
hot and then hitting on her trying to
get her in bed
i never liked that either i understand
where neil is coming from now that he
doesn't like it but that book actually
you know i think i i like i liked the
book i actually liked it better than his
second book the truth
i'm not a big fan of for a few reasons
you know but
that's another subject but i don't i'm
not a fan of pickup in general
but it did help me get out of my comfort
zone and get me out talking to people in
general
and then to to women as well and
and so i i learned to to date
successfully i started getting
girlfriends started having sex started
having a relationship
and guys started saying robert what are
you doing it's working teach us and
i never thought i'd be a dating guru and
and but i just started teaching
guys a lot of it just has to do with
being authentic being confident
setting the tone and leading being
comfortable in your own skin
living life on your terms and that's
real attractive
to women in general it's not going to
attract every woman but it's attractive
to to the feminine
now i tell guys if you if you're walking
across a room just because you like a
woman's tits and you think oh she'd make
a good girlfriend cause i like her tits
that's the stupidest reason to go talk
to a woman i mean you know
i'm surprised you're saying that where's
the wisdom behind that the wisdom is
what happens what do you know about this
person she may be
entitled she may be spoiled she may be
worthy she may be stupid she may talk
too much she may be a drunk but hey i
like her tits
let's go talk to her and and we men make
some pretty
simple you know relationships that don't
serve us well
so i i i learned to talk to everybody i
just became more of a social animal
and so that's really what i teach men is
is really just how to be
more social how to expand their social
and emotional intelligence
but the thing is the stuff that that i
learned dating also
really does help my relationship i've
been married four years now to my wife
lupita mexican woman i met her down here
puerto vallarta and um in this in the
skill sets that made me a competent
dater keep her turned on to me
four years into our marriage right and
and she loves me to death she thinks i'm
amazing she wants
our our our biggest conflict in our
marriage is she wants more sex than i do
so most guys go hey i want to sign up
for that one
um and she says would you rather have it
be the other way and i said nope nope
this works just fine
so going back to what i was talking
about a little bit earlier
of that differentiated self that means
you're living life on your terms
you're comfortable in your own skin you
like you you like you how you get up and
live your life every day
and my experience when a man is doing
that
living this differentiated living life
on his own terms
living with his purpose and his passion
that makes him amazingly attractive to
the feminine whether it's the woman he's
been married to for 20 years
or just women in the street my wife is
the typical
jealous latina and i tell you what she
points
out whenever women are checking me out
walking in front of me too much jutting
a hip out
giving me a little cleavage bend over
the waitress when the waitress standing
a little too close to me
she points all that out and i just
turned 65 a week or so ago
and this still happens all the time and
typically when i'm with her and
typically with much younger women
and it's not because i'm flirting with
them it's not because
you know i'm so amazingly handsome or or
i'm so amazingly rich
there i i just over time i'm comfortable
in my skin and i live life on my terms
my wife finds that attractive
so do other women and paradoxically the
fact that other women find me
attractive makes my wife jealous but it
makes me more attractive to her as well
she even tells me that she says i get
jealous when i see other women
you know trying to get your attention
she goes but it turns me on
yeah it rouses me so
whether you're a single guy guy in a
relationship there's just there's just
something about living life on your
terms
that just makes and what really makes a
big difference
is you quit really caring so much is
this where a person attracted to me i
don't know it doesn't matter
is is is my woman this way it really
doesn't matter
quite as much in fact one thing i've
found that has
over the four years married to to my
wife lupita the thing that's made the
marriage
the best is to be equally okay
with whether she's happy or unhappy
equally okay with whether or not this
marriage makes it or doesn't make it
then that gets me out of those nice guy
patterns of trying to fix everything
solve everything make her happy
and just be me just keep loving her and
just stay connected to her not trying to
fix anything
and that lets her work through her own
stuff and we get through it quicker
so again is that being just being happy
in your own skin and living life on your
terms
[Music]